mes abonnés ont commencé à grimper etc
et
tu as plus de 964 sur snapchat et plus
de 538 sur insta voilà donc voilà ils
ont commencé à grimper
progressivement mais très rapidement
également s'il y a une ascension
vraiment fulgurante mais moi aujourd'hui
je me rends pas compte du tout du nombre
de personnes par qui je suis suivie et
plus donc plus les personnes me
suivaient plus le harcèlement s'empirer
ça a vraiment commencé le vrai
harcèlement je pars du harcèlement
dangereux à la naissance de ma fille
c'est Anna donc c'est mon rôle de mère
qui a directement été pointé parce que
voilà être maman à 19 ans etc enfin
c'est comment aujourd'hui mais une maman
qui expose ça à taux etc on va vite la
juger on va tout remettre sur l'âge etc
et c'est à ce moment là que vraiment le
harcèlement il a été intense vraiment à
quoi toi plus que les autres
influenceuses parce que voilà tu es ce
que tu cartonnes encore plus que je
dirais pas que je cartonne mais je
montre enfin je suis sans filtre la vie
d'une personne lambda je la montre je
l'expose voilà vous prenez n'importe
quelle personne et c'est comme si elle
prenait son téléphone elle se filmage 24
voilà au final vous filmez
quoi fumer je me réveille le matin je
prends mon téléphone voilà c'est naturel
quoi vraiment c'est devenu pour vous
c'est un mode de vie c'est votre métier
oui donc le matin vous votre téléphone
c'est votre travail exactement et donc
vous commencez à vous filmer ou filmer
tout ce qui se passe dans la famille
quand il y a des problèmes quand il y a
des tout c'est quoi les trucs que vous
avez filmés qui ont vécu qui ont fait le
plus de vues mon mariage c'est une vidéo
YouTube dessus après combien de
personnes le mariage sur Youtube un
million il me semble ça va mais du coup
il pleut plein d'autres choses des
péripéties qui peuvent arriver à plein
de gens comme des cambriolages des
choses comme ça en fait à chaque fois
qu'il m'arrive quelque chose le film ça
veut dire que je vais acheter du pain je
vais le filmer je vais marcher je vais
dire que je marche enfin voilà quoi
c'est naturel
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé vous avez été
harcelé qu'est-ce qu'on vous a fait
parce que c'est vrai que ça a été un
moment très violent moi j'entendais
parler que de ça d'ailleurs j'avais vu
de nombreux postes concernant voilà et
c'est vrai que qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
déjà le je pense la chose qui a été le
plus dur dans mon harcèlement ça a été
le fait qu'on ramène les assistantes
sociales chez moi pour remettre en cause
l'éducation de ma fille que j'aime et
que j'embrasse j'aime plus que tout il
faut qu'on dit à travers quoi à travers
les vidéos voilà voilà exactement ils
ont pris des vidéos hors contexte par
exemple une vidéo où je suis dans la
piscine je filme ma fille elle est
également dans la piscine mais il y a
personne autour du cadre de ma fille
elle embrassard etc et elle dit que il y
a personne dans la piscine pour
surveiller la petite mais moi je la file
enfin la petite donc je suis dans la
piscine aussi c'est des choses comme ça
et malheureusement les les assistantes
sociales etc elles sont pas trop qu'à
les réseaux sociaux elles ont pas
d'ailleurs quand elles sont venus elles
m'ont dit enfin réseaux sociaux nous on
connaît pas trop ça et on a vu des
vidéos des choses comme ça mais il faut
voir le contexte derrière quoi
c'est vrai que c'est incroyable et
derrière ça je savais pas moi donc
rendez compte ces vidéos ont fait que
l'assistante sociale sont venus ça a été
le pire truc cambriolage aussi qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé
en fait j'étais au Mali avec avec mon
mari et que vous étiez au Maldives en
fait ils sont montés chez moi j'habite
j'habitais dans un immeuble au quatrième
étage et ils sont fait passer pour EDF
aller vraiment prévenir les voisins qui
auraient des travaux ils ont cassé la
porte et voilà et c'est ouais c'est la
vidéo qu'on voit ici
après il y a eu le harcèlement il est il
est quoi il est quotidien ou ça se calme
ah non il est toutes les minutes toutes
les secondes en fait il y a un hashtag à
mon nom d'ailleurs c'est un peu aussi
pour ça que je suis venu parce que
Twitter bah écoute fin à personne ne
prend en comment dire ne prend en
considération mais mais enfin mes cris
on va dire tu souffres oui oui c'est une
situation très pesant oui toute les
toutes les minutes il y a toutes les
minutes il y a des tweets et en fait je
suis en caisse tu encaisses et au bout
d'un moment bah voilà tu craques comme
ça et tu fais des pauses de deux
semaines et tu reviens et je prends un
peu de souffle et tu reviens
vous êtes pas bien au moment où je vais
arrêter
c'est maintenant c'est votre métier oui
bien sûr que c'est mon métier
un moyen de vous exprimer alors quand
vous parlez de harcèlement pour que les
gens comprennent bien c'est quoi des
tweets toutes les minutes ils disent
quoi
la vérité des choses tellement basiques
enfin des choses qui pour vous sont
normales mais pour elle non par exemple
je peux lire ou je sais pas oui voyage à
New York qui va être payé grâce au drama
fausses séparation TPMP victime de
harcèlement les très forte et puis de
vicieuse alors déjà faut savoir que moi
quand il y a un drama quand il se passe
quelque chose s'ensuit généralement une
pause de réseaux sociaux donc je fais ni
mon travail ni mes postes ni rien du
tout je préviens les marques qui
pourront témoigner que désolé je suis
pas bien je quitte les réseaux une ou
deux semaines pour me ressourcer donc
c'est pas du tout ça n'a aucun aucune
arrière-pensée financière ou ou il y a
pas de vis en fait c'est vraiment ce qui
se passe je l'expose et n'importe quoi
en fait vraiment d'accord alors tes
enfants tu les exposé énormément sur tes
réseaux sociaux c'est ça aussi qui fait
que il y a énormément de gens qui qui
mettent des postes parfois vraiment qui
sont
difficiles encaisser parce que c'est
vrai que quand on parle de tes enfants
mais tu as choisi de montrer ta vie
montrer tes enfants
est-ce que toi tu tu crains pas qui qui
t'envoye quand ils seront grands
c'est une question qui est posée
forcément bien évidemment pour ma fille
mon fils il est pas il est pas exposé
pour l'instant et je parlais de ça en
plus il y a pas longtemps dans mes
stories je disais est-ce que je fais la
même erreur c'est pas et aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on comprend bien poupette et
c'est tu peux pas revenir en arrière ça
y est maintenant tu es pris dans le
système
tu as choisi de montrer ta vie c'est ça
ça cartonne pour toi c'est un truc de
fou voilà et derrière
forcément il y a des jalousies il y a
des moqueries il y a des du harcèlement
comme tu as dit il y a des choses très
violentes derrière que tu peux lire ou
que tu peux voir tous les jours et qui
qui t'arrive mais c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui est-ce que tu regrettes ton
choix ce que tu dis j'aurais peut-être
dû faire autre chose ou est-ce que tu es
heureuse
est-ce que je regrette mon choix non
j'ai à côté j'ai incroyable communauté
très engagée tu as une vie incroyable
comment ça
je pense que tu gagnes très bien ta vie
il y a plein de gens aussi qui se disent
c'est un exemple aussi pour il y en a
plein qui veut devenir la nouvelle
poupée c'est très flatteur mais
vous suivez un peu mes stories je sais
pas moi
c'est pour ça
cartonne mais c'est très très basique tu
racontes voilà tu racontes
et ça j'ai du mal à
en fait c'est un moment c'est vrai que
tu as fait tes vidéos moi je vois tes
vidéos c'est les mêmes que que tu as
toujours fait mais aujourd'hui tu es
énormément suivi et il y a beaucoup de
gens qui qui alors il y a forcément côté
suivi quand tu as le temps de succès il
y a des gens qui qui t'adorent et puis
il y a des gens qui qui t'aiment moins
et toi comme ton métier c'est sur les
réseaux forcément tu tu lis tout tu
t'intéresses à tout et donc tu vois des
choses de tous les jours qui peuvent te
blesser
mais aujourd'hui ça fait partie du
métier non il y a des choses il y a des
la critique etc moi j'accepte pas en
fait que qu'on me mette en insécurité
comme là par exemple il y a pas
longtemps elles ont mis l'adresse de la
crèche de ma fille ça c'est pas possible
ça à ce moment-là là ça devient trop ça
fait peur là à ce moment-là moi je me
suis fait cambrioler elle divulguer mon
adresse tous les jours sur le hashtag
enfin il y a un hashtag poupette Kenza
où il y a même aujourd'hui des
trafiquants de drogue de je ne sais où
qui mettent hashtag toupet Kenza et par
l'espagnol pour faire leur pub enfin
c'est vraiment devenu j'ai l'impression
je te vois tous les jours tu es en top 8
et sur les réseaux on parle de toi tu es
entendantes c'est un truc de fou tous
les jours donc c'est c'est incroyable
c'est vrai que c'est pas pesant
ça dépend dans quelle situation par
exemple quand je vais accoucher et que
je vois que tout le monde se réjouit
pour moi etc ça me fait énormément
plaisir mais après oui quand quand c'est
mauvais ça fait mal mais dans tous les
cas le fait qu'on parle de nous tous les
jours toutes les minutes si je me suis
réveillé à 11h oh là là elle dort encore
cette fin des trucs comme ça tu as
l'impression que tu es pas maintenant
ils sont guidés par l'humain en fait
c'est plus du tout ça y est tu es enfin
tu es un robot en fait on te guide et tu
fais pour pour prouver ton mari dit quoi
il est pas d'accord avec eux
il est avec toi voilà et on a ouvert un
institut il y a pas longtemps et gère
la vie générale d'un peu tout le monde
que je devrais moins en montrer etc
j'ai vraiment j'ai commencé à vraiment
bien filtrer comme dans ma situation
actuelle là j'essaye de filtrer un peu
ce que ce qui se passe quoi alors on a
la vidéo de cambriolage après
cambriolage
ils ont cambrioler la maison ma mère
elle vient de m'appeler ils ont cassé la
porte et tout ils
sont rentrés je pensais
viens mon chéri
[Musique]
sérieux c'est rien mon bébé tu m'as pas
vu ça y est tu as eu peur et puis ils
ont laissé ça sur le lit c'est pour ça
qu'elle allait avoir l'argent
et voilà la tringle ils l'ont fait
tomber
on regarde l'état de la porte
voilà l'état de la porte
voilà
c'est rigolo alors il y a plein de gens
qui se disent aussi peut-être je viens
de te faire cambrioler tu vas me mettre
ça sur les sur les réseaux ce que tu as
pas peur derrière est-ce que tu c'est la
seule réaction que tu as c'est pour ça
il y a des gens qui te critiquent
derrière mais toi c'est le réflexe que
tu as tout de suite je contrôle pas trop
mes émotions moi je suis parfois je
regrette ce que je mets je vais jamais
dire que j'ai jamais rien regretté
malheureusement tout ce que je dis
aujourd'hui ça prend tellement des
proportions que même si je regrette au
bout de 5 minutes ça y est c'est déjà
partout en fait donc il y a plein de
choses ça je le regrette pas c'était mes
émotions ça m'a fait du bien de partager
ça j'ai eu des témoignages de personnes
qui se sont fait cambrioler etc un
cambriolage ce n'est pas à prendre à la
légère c'est un traumatisme c'est un
c'est excusez-moi du terme mais c'est
comme un viol un cambriolage on est
rentré chez vous on a vu on dormait on a
vu où vous l'avez etc donc ouais j'ai eu
du mal à m'embête j'ai déménagé
directement de toute façon ton mari il
est heureux quand même de la vie comme
ça il sait que
je sais pas franchement
de me regarder là
tu es bien je kiffe quoi ta vie tu
kiffes quand même cette heureuse oui je
suis heureuse oui il y a pire dans la
vie à Pierre mais tu te sens quand même
tu as le poids de tout ce qui voilà tout
tout
c'est aujourd'hui je m'empêche de
partager plein d'autres choses que
j'aimerais directement dire etc mais en
fait elle met tellement des bâtons dans
les roues sur plein de choses que par
exemple je vais aller au resto elles
vont annuler ma réservation du resto si
je vais dire les filles je vais manger
un restaurant on voit la Tour Eiffel
elles vont savoir enfin elles vont taper
les restos de Tour Eiffel elles
appellent toi j'ai été avec mon mari et
elles avaient annulé la réservation je
suis arrivée et je me suis plantée il y
avait pas de réservation voilà
maintenant
que j'y suis donc tout le temps ton mari
il en a pas marre que tu sois tout le
temps sur ton tel
et on peut plus
vivre un jour il va le prendre il va le
casser
non
Matthieu non c'est parce que moi tu
travailles donc c'est très bien tu fais
des choses et tout ça donc c'est une
génération qui est pas forcément un
autre mais c'est très bien il y a qu'une
chose vraiment vraiment je pars de ne
pas ou que je comprends pas c'est que tu
es pris la décision pour ta fille de la
montrer c'est à dire que bonne ou
mauvaise tu peux plus reculer et un jour
elle te le reprochera peut-être et quand
tu vois la violence déjà ton petit
niveau de ce que peut être la violence
d'une telle visibilité comme comment tu
peux ça comment tu peux montrer ton
enfant comme ça à l'intérieur sans son
accord c'est à dire que peut-être que
plus tard cette fille-là va avoir des
problèmes sans son accord alors en fait
déjà ça je vais pas dire ça a été malgré
moi parce que ça a été un choix mais
c'est Anna à chaque fois que je sortais
dans la rue on essayait de me voler des
photos c'était invivable je la cachais
je la mettais sous des couvertures etc
ça c'est le premier point dans tous les
cas elle aurait fuité comme mon fils a
fuité je marchais à l'aéroport il y a
pas longtemps on apprend en photo mon
fils à mon insu on l'a publié
vraiment tu la mets comme ça
ma fille absolument pas non pas du tout
elle est très aimée elle est enfin voilà
ça a été une continuité pour moi elles
m'ont vu marier elles m'ont vu mettre au
monde cet enfant et la montrer en fait
ça a été un peu malgré moi mais mon
choix il a été influencé par ma
communauté oui je voulais leur montrer
ma fille mon bijou m'a ma beauté ma vie
c'est vrai qu'en fait tu es victime de
ton succès victime de comme un ce que
disent les gens disent c'est comme un
engrenage c'est un engrenage en fait un
engrenage c'est ça il y a du bon il y a
du mauvais et tu peux plus t'arrêter
parce que en vrai même poupette on va
dire c'est c'est franchement c'est un
business incroyable
toutes les marques te veulent tu fais
énormément de placement aussi enfin tu
fais des tout le monde te suit c'est ça
c'est un truc de fou à chaque fois que
tu dis quelque chose comme tu dis c'est
repris donc à un moment tu dis comment
revenir en arrière non même quand on a
athée un mec qui disait quand tu
dévisses tu dévisses non mais c'est vrai
qu'en gros tu dis comment comment on
revient en arrière parce que tu dois
avoir un train de vie tes enfants alors
excuse-moi je sais que voilà tu montres
tout euh voilà sur les réseaux on dit
quoi pour l'instant ils voilà c'est
c'est je t'ai parlé de ton mari tout ça
donc voilà c'est voilà on va voir ok on
va voir mais c'est ce que tu en fait
aujourd'hui tu peux plus revenir en
arrière c'est où tu te dis stop et en
fait j'arrête tout et je vais aller
travailler un travail je vais trouver un
travail j'ai pas un autre travail normal
j'ai envie de dire entre guillemets ou
bien je suis obligé
mon hashtag il a tellement pris tes
proportions que je comprends pas les
milliers de mails que j'ai envoyé à
Twitter qui qui les ai rien fait pour ça
on croirait que ça les amuse de voir la
publicité sur un hashtag qui prône le
harcèlement toute la journée
enfin je sais pas c'est pas un tweet
c'est pas deux c'est tous les jours
depuis deux ans et demi c'est vraiment
un pesant c'est pas les réseaux ça
demain tu fais de la télévision et ça
peut être à partir du moment où tu
deviens célèbre que son état animateur
ça n'a rien à voir là tu parles tu
parles tu parles d'un truc et tu connais
pas ce qu'elle dit ça n'a rien à voir là
excuse-moi je t'aime beaucoup mais là ça
n'a rien à voir elle elle parle d'un
truc poupette elle est tous les jours
elle est tous les jours en top tendance
à tous les jours tous les jours non
parce que tu sais pas quoi tu parles tu
parles d'un truc poupette à chaque fois
qu'elle poste un truc c'est la folie ce
soir on savait qu'elle est venue dans
dans Touche pas en poste ça a été la
folie toute la journée donc aujourd'hui
quel serait ton message pour pas être
parce que il y a des gens qui disent
aussi elles se plaint elle a une vie
géniale ça va si elle a deux trois trucs
et des des commentaires tous les jours
sur les réseaux qu'est-ce qu'elle s'en
fout elle est franchement elle est toute
voilà elle a elle a un taf magnifique
qu'est-ce qu'elle vient nous emmerder
mais qu'est-ce que tu réponds à ces
gens-là
je réponds faut le vivre pour le
comprendre et peu importe ce qu'il y a
derrière dans tout le cas personne ne
mérite d'être harcelé d'être moindre
fait chez Joseph et alors toi tu le
joues aussi parce que tu as dit tu
montres ta vie donc voilà c'est en fait
c'est le
comme je disais tout à l'heure au niveau
des critiques et tout ça c'est
totalement normal tu prends ce cet
aspect des réseaux sociaux tu prends
aussi les critiques et tout ce qu'il y a
derrière mais mettre en danger les
enfants etc ça c'est quelque chose que
il y a même pas que ça il y a les
secrets professionnels qui est pas
respecté à la sécurité sociale
j'accouche on le met des règles on met
direct sur Twitter le nom de mes enfants
etc alors je l'ai même pas encore
annoncé enfin plein de choses comme ça
des choses vraiment c'est incroyable ah
oui non c'est n'importe quoi franchement
c'est le secret professionnel il est
absolument pas respecté ce que tu es
heureuse aujourd'hui
oui je vais continuer je vais pas leur
donner raison en tout cas non qu'est-ce
que tu auras à leur dire à tous ceux qui
t'harcèdent à tous ceux qui te laissent
des messages des tous les haters class
énormément de messages tous les jours tu
aurais quoi leur dire ce soir avancer
faites votre vie arrêtez de
moi c'est ça parfait ça c'est Larousse
et non non mais c'est vrai donc ouais tu
veux plus mais c'est donc tu voudrais
qu'il y a que les gens qui t'aiment non
mais ou des gens qui t'aiment pas mais
qui dit voilà mais pas des gens qui se
tranquilles
[Musique]
elles font elles font des gros problèmes
elles envoient des messages à mon mari
et elle vont très loin elles vont très
loin
très très loin ça dissout les liens
familiaux etc c'est au-delà des réseaux
sociaux là